pas je vais maintenant laisser la parole
à pierre charon une fine gâchette et qui
va nous parler de la chasse et des
valeurs traditionnelles
merci beaucoup alors d'abord un constat
l'arrivée du président sarkozy je veux
dire c'est très pratique de parler le
dernier en présence du président parce
qu on a trois secondes et 35 communes
est pas là dans les trois secondes
d'abord un constat un million quatre
cent mille permis de chasse trois
millions d'électeurs chasse et il
fallait donc réagir
attention cette version qu'au dessus du
monde de la chasse il y avait des drones
jay marine le pen qui arrivait et qui
était en chasse deux chasseurs on a donc
réagi en créant d'avoir un secrétariat
national à la chasse ce qu'avait
président sarkozy ce qui m'a autorisé à
revoir toutes les fédérations
ce qui n'est pas un parti politique
toutes les fédérations de chasse de
france présidée par l'excellent monsieur
baudin et nous avons un beau matin du
mois de juillet
tendu la main aux chasseurs c'était en
juillet dernier et le président sarkozy
flangardé de ses principaux
collaborateurs a reçu le bureau de la
chasse française
et là on leur a proposé une chose par
rapport à ce qu'ils entendaient et la
petite musique des sirènes qui passait
qui venait de là où vous savez on le
relit voilà nous on ne traite pas comme
un parti on vous offre des places
éligibles
si vous les prenez on vous donnera dans
la plupart des cas la possibilité
d'avoir les présidences de commissions
de commissions écologie et développement
durable
si vous passez cet accord avec nous
première chose au lieu d'avoir toujours
le chasseur en fin de course mais qui
n'est jamais élu mais qui est présent
comme parfois autres fronts vous avez
que certaines femmes c'est fini ce temps
là les lois sont occupés et heureusement
et on leur a promis la botte et en même
temps un programme cynégétique de
qualité avec une éthique et c'est ça que
nous avons signé avec le président
sarkozy
et ça a marché ensuite il a fallu
expliquer à nos têtes de listes à nos
chefs de file ou c'était pas facile de
retirer
mr pour mettre un chasseur il a fallu
parfois attendre un peu le bras j'ai
toujours un peu difficile dans les
communes sans l'investiture mais a fini
bien
car en réalité comme il y à une
association de chasse par village c'est
un maillage extraordinaires que nous
avons et je rappelle ces chiffres c'est
énorme
alors on l'a fait ça a marché
résultat des courses on a fait rentrer
60 chasseurs dans les nouvelles régions
métropolitaines et dix spécialistes si
léger tic dans les exécutifs alors à
partant de ce moment là l'accord a été
tenue
qu'allons-nous faire ensuite les lois
biodiversité sont arrivés d'abord à
l'assemblée et à l'assemblée vous savez
que les écolos sont très nombreux ont
beaucoup d'influx ans et siège au moment
où les autres ne siège pas c'est à dire
qu'on a eu des amendements et des textes
scélérats anti chasse qui sont arrivés
au sénat mais l'intérêt du sénat c'est
que nous on a repris le sénat et que le
groupe chasse et bien il se compose de
80 chasseurs
ça ne s'invente pas avec jean-noël
cardoux nous avons donc repris et annulé
tous les articles anti chasse au sénat
et madame ségolène royal qui s'y connaît
parfaitement
envoyé dans tout ça à l'assemblée en
attendant des jours meilleurs mais je
dois vous dire qu'il va falloir que nos
députés
cette phase il soit beaucoup plus
nombreux pour défendre ce que nous nous
avons bloqué avec le groupe chasse qui
comprend des socialistes aussi et les
communistes ya pas de verre c'est la
seule chose eh bien il va falloir qu'il
s'y mette pour qu'ensuite ses textes
soit définitif et qu'on puisse continuer
notre aventure avec cette fédération
nationale de la chasse qui ne demande
qu'à être traités qu'à donner son avis
on ne s'embête pas chez les républicains
mais on a fait l'offre en premier on a
tendu la main et c'est à ce qu'a fait
nicolas sarkozy
ils se sont très contents ils nous ont
remerciés l' aventure continue le 15
mars se déroulera le grand congrès la
fédération nationale de la chasse
j'encourage tous les parlementaires à se
rendre dans les assemblées générales les
assemblées générales départementales de
chasseurs c'est entre 500 et 1500
chasseurs par département
moi j'en vois comme l'année dernière un
argumentaire
les députés à tous les sénateurs afin
qu'il puisse répondre à la plupart des
questions parce que il faut y aller
lancer assemblée générale et ils sont
pas politiques
ce qui nous intéresse c'est de savoir si
vous autorisez les charges
additionnelles
et si la cigogne peut passer tel jour à
telle heure en février ou pas parce que
là une seule population de cigognes bon
c'est comme ça où les oies sauvages
alors à partir de ce moment là
l'aventuré continue
ils sont là pour six ans on les aide ils
nous aident
on va continuer et puis peut-être qu'ils
s'en souviendront au vent droit des
présidentielles de savoir que les gens
tendu la main et que ça pourra continuer
façon un peu plus sérieuse lorsque dora
a pris le pouvoir
je vous remercie